non-minimalists
why do we cling to unhappy relationships
and how do we let go of them
oh boy i'm like the king of clinging to
unhappy relationships i mean not so much
anymore but like back in the day i just
like it there's a sense of security
there's a sense of uh knowing the
outcome so even though it's a pernicious
relationship i would have at least i
knew what was going to happen so there's
all these like you know you feel like
you have a little bit of control because
you know the outcome uh you feel secure
because you don't you know you're not
going to be throwing things that you
don't know of even if they're negative
things that get thrown your way at least
you know they're coming so i think
that's a big piece of it and then you
know there's a comfortable aspect to it
right well they always say the hell you
know is better than the heaven you don't
amen so
with my parents the way i grew up um you
know my mother i bless her heart but she
had a lot of food issues rage-a-holic
and my father was very much of an
enabler and the kindest most homeless
guy but so i always was like well that's
why i have the relationships and the
marriages and thank god the divorces i
have but i was recreating that because
it felt familiar so i was like well at
least i know mom and dad stayed together
for 60 something years so this can't be
that bad and i think it's just
familiarity and the fear to create
something new like it's really really
uncomfortable to have different types of
friendships where get this they're equal
oh man i would be always paying for
everything be the caretaker all my
friends nobody put takes out a credit
card you know no it's lisa's
everything's on me and then it's like oh
god
no one this is what my biggest pride
after um covid
because of kovid thankfully the only one
good thing that happened for me was
everybody in my life
needs me and i need them versus them
just needing me
and of course the goal is to not have a
need at all but for now it's progress so
i think it's just recreating that
childhood stuff for me it always was i
still fight that like i had a friend
make fun of me one time uh like we go
out to this little diner it wasn't it
was in missoula montana it's a cheap
place i was like oh don't worry guys i
got it
and she was like okay mister i'll get
everything yes and like i didn't realize
how
some people just want to pay for their
own meal but like there is something
well i have a lot of like um starving
artist friends so i try to like
contribute as much as i can to them
whether it's like buying tickets to
their show or like paying for dinner
when we're out and about but
um
but yeah it's hard for me to get past
that still sometimes oh that's a rough
one i remember hearing an interview with
chelsea handler on stern where she was
talking about of course i pick up the
tab every time because i make the most
money and i have to fight that now
and i even okay i'll tell you honestly i
said to the guys on my podcast shameless
plug loser with the dream available
everywhere that i said look i'm gonna go
to la and do a ton of podcasts that i've
had
friends on that i love that are and i'm
gonna see all my friends
i may
when you start making money from pot
this podcast of ours
ask you for that money back i knew my
flight was free i mean you know i live
cheap now but i may ask you for that
money back just so there's never
resentment and they as
people but still with day jobs making
nothing from comedy said you're
absolutely right
nothing
is worth resenting us and i'm like oh my
god this is so cool so i had that thing
where i'd have to always pull out the
credit card and this was hilarious once
i was at a diner with a friend of mine
who's a best-selling author and as a
joke i was just spoofing bridesmaids i
took out that platinum card the amex
card that's really heavy the one made of
steel
darling don't worry everyone should see
one of these once in their life and she
goes oh how about one of these and she
had the black card
and we laughed so hard and i'm like it's
but it is a thing we have to fight yeah
it's the good fight people want to feel
like equals i think yes
yes sarah
why do we cling to unhappy relationships
there's a few things to understand here
first off is
that it's not the relationship meaning
the other person that is making you
happy there's also not a relate this
thing called a relationship a separate
thing there's you and there's the other
person and when you come together we
call it a relationship the other person
is not making you unhappy you and your
expectations of the other person are
making you unhappy and so understanding
that it's only an unhappy relationship
because you want one thing out of it
but you're getting something else out of
the relationship so how do you let it go
there is no how there's a simply an
understanding letting go is not
something you do it's something you stop
doing the only way to let go is to stop
clinging to a relationship now maybe
this is a toxic relationship for you
maybe it's something that you are
clinging to even though you know that
it's never going to bring you what you
want
instead of calling it unhappy let's call
it what it is it's a relationship that's
making you miserable there's two ways to
change that the first way to change it
is to understand that my expectations
are what's making me miserable the
second way to change it
is to
understand that that misery
is going to be there in any relationship
for which you have an expectation now
you can have a high standard a high
standard simply means living in the
moment doing the best you can putting
the best foot forward the expectation
means i need to get something out of it
so the reason you're clinging right now
is because you feel like you need
to have this relationship and you need
to get satisfaction or happiness or
whatever those things are not external
they can't be pursued a relationship can
never make you happy only you can make
you happy
god i love that you know what i preach
what i love about this podcast he lets
us take a little shot at trying it he
lets us try to answer then he knows
that's right exactly he's like i got
this [ __ ] right yeah don't worry let me
let me pretend these two have anything
to say it's a fantastic story but that's
so true man that's that's really don't
worry sean will just edit you out and
post it's fine i figured i figured my
mic has never been on this whole time
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
percent advertisement free